з хвилину закону правило трону це клару
ваніно 30 березня
за критику і в Україні, і за її
мишами той факт швензу база піддаватися
на троні декларанті шукай
антикорупційних активістів
засудила і в брюсселі і в берліні щось
coupe відомі низу зовнішньополітичного
відомства frn та дайте підписаний
президентом порошенка закон з прямого та
державна політику
навчальному на премію у не матч у них
пізнань новий закон іншу проти тих
хто сам бореться з корупцією у алани не
пити сердитесь державних садів циви
відходить на задній план але поки що з
твориться вираз із чим у супере джаффе
тіні та антикорупційної політики заходи
мати жива тася проти них, хто ставить собі
зам цю боротьбу з корупцією та берліною
шановні загинули про мою дружину ту картину
ідеальності суп і гарчати інтересам
україни esp одягаєте над нею
закону на ch прозорого та депутати
адже європарламенту не мічені ребекка
хармс
вона називала чесним розчаруванням тягну
порошенко не в цю вов закон за все
закладки євро депутатів та єврочиновники
та 5 hand in ukraine на троні декларації
в Україні та одружена і україна з праймалу
сяк прорив про боротьбу з корупцією і я моя
на відвіз корупцію в цих риб ми вона
спокої частіше після великого успіху як у
гидко не тисне паве дальності голови
dfs на насирова т.п.
з їжі до кларування чола плювала все
храм один особливий у багатіїв c і d перед
ви рилася в інструмент для морських тигра
організацій я думаю не дави заради плутати
авто чиновники в борг ти вести в
мистецтві тебе треба віра цін обіцяні
відпочивайте
проти законів виступав і приставлені
до США канада то великої британії то
президента України ціни запливла документ
вин підписавши обіцяв [ __ ] і разом з
хвилину закону